bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour la suite de ce 16e de finale du
championnat du monde féminin 2015 entre
la numéro un française marie sebag et
l'ukrainienne anna ou chez nina ce sont
maintenant les tie breaks
après le match nul en partie longue deux
parties rapides avant éventuellement des
blitz de départage mais enfin on n'en
est pas là et puis on va voir quelque
chose de tout à fait nouveau dans ce
match puisque en fait on va voir la
fameuse variante du décalage horaire et
oui la variante du décalage horaire très
très rare
alors je vais vous l'expliquer vous
allez voir pourquoi voici le plan ici de
la rue si vous voyez ici avec moscou
bien entendu avec les frontières voilà
l'ukraine lsi les couleurs sont
différentes c'est à cause du décalage
horaire donc ici en fait à moscou il ya
une heure de plus qu en ukraine y voilà
alors le problème c'est que en fait ce
qui s'est passé dans la première partie
marie avait des blancs et est arrivée
bien entendu pour son match et ou chez
nina n'est pas n'est pas venu jouer
voilà et alors on s'est demandé ce qui
s'est passé est bête c'est en fait c'est
son téléphone portable qui apparemment
c'est réinitialiser et qui a remis leur
d'ukraine
voilà donc pour elle à 13h et bien fait
ce n'est pas très dur ça trois heures la
balle à 15 heures l'après midi heure
locale à moscou 13 heures en france et
bien pour elle il n'était que
12h voilà donc elle avait encore une
heure selon son téléphone qui s'était
réinitialiser en heure d'ukraine et non
pas en heures de sotchi à sotchi se
trouve ici là sur le bord de la mer
noire
ici ça c'est la mer noire ceux ci et par
là dans le coin et donc c'est à l'heure
russe et il ya une heure de décalage
avec l'ukraine
et voilà donc le danger évidemment si
l'on va dans un autre pays c'est de ne
pas suivre leur local et ce qui s'est
passé les dons du coup elle a perdu sur
tapis vert la première partie donc ça
c'est bon c'est extrêmement triste pour
le sport mais bon c'est la règle du jeu
marie l elle était là à l'heure donc
elle gagne cette première partie sur
tapis vert maintenant donc on a la
deuxième partie elle mène d'un point
marie face donc à auch et nina qui a les
blancs et qui doit maintenant donc du
coup absolument l'emporter pour essayer
maintenant d'arriver au tie-break blitz
voilà d'arriver au blitz et marie lui
suffit d'une partie nul donc pour
remporter le match et se qualifier pour
les seizièmes de finale donc après cette
fameuse variante du décalage horaire une
variante qui fera date
c'est le mot donc c'est parti pour osh
et nina avec qualif 3 c'est qu'elle
avait joué déjà dans la partie longue
face à marier avec les blancs et des 5 c
4 à valence est déjà un peu différent
puisqu'elle avait joué avec g3 fou g2
rappelez vous un début de type catalan
et là on rentre dans quelque chose on va
voir ensuite après ses 6 e 3 voilà ça y
est sans doute maintenant le fou ici va
sortir sur eux deux ou pourquoi pas sur
des trois plus tard font déjouer des 80
sans doute mais on n'aura pas la
variante avec g3 ou pourtant ou chez
nina avait réussi à dominer
marie dans l'ouverture et a gagné un
pion net avec une très belle position
mais comme on l'a vu marie est arrivée à
revenir dans la partie de manière tout à
fait extraordinaire avec un très beau
jeu dynamique kalyev si ce qu'avait
laissé 3e 6 b 3 donc là bien sûr les
blancs jouent en b3 envisage en cas de
présence et cartes de reprendre très
certainement du pion pour ramener un
pion vers le centre toujours important
et puis sortir le fou sur b2 avec une
très belle diagonale pour ce fou
notamment un fou qui pourrait devenir en
food attaques contre le roc blanc le roc
noir pardon donc on continue cavale et
b17 ça c'est normal
regardez le problème on avait parlé
d'ailleurs dans la partie précédente où
il y avait la catalane où on avait dit
le problème quand on joue comme ça c'est
extrêmement solide bien su en terme de
chaîne de pions mais alors dans la
partie président de mari avait réussi à
sortir le fou avant d'avoir fermé la
structure est là le fouillent temps
fermé voilà le fou c'est 8 il est bloqué
derrière ses pions alors c'est un des
problèmes des noirs c'est à dire que bon
il joue avec une pièce qui pour
l'instant attend son heure en fait un
ce fou ne pourra sortir que quand des
échanges auront pu se faire donc en
attendant les noirs pourront pas
facilement lier leur tour et donc avoir
un jeu disons souple en défense mais
devront un peu faire de l'acrobatie faux
b2
6 très bien regardez comme le fou noir
maintenant par contre lui est tout à
fait à l'aise puisque les fous étant sur
blanc le fou noir et très très libre de
coulisses et comme il veut sur les cases
noires dame ces deux très bien joli coup
de développement on prépare un futur
petit rock avec liaison des tours et en
jouant la dame en c2 on permettra au
tour d'être lié donc de venir au centre
et en plus cette dame en c2 vise les cas
à la casse de central 4 ça peut être
utile plus tard ça empêche notamment ce
cavalier devenir 1,4 bon de toute façon
c'est déjà protégé aussi par lequel les
c3 message est là dessus et puis aussi
pourquoi pas mettre une tour en c1 et un
doublement sur la colonne c'est voilà
enfin tout ça est à peu prêt classique
les normes une position très solide
petit rock foule de 2 à 6 alors clasico
si on regardait alors bon on pourrait se
dire encore un pion sur blanc ça fait
quand même beaucoup de bien sur blanc
ils sont presque tous hurlant un sauf le
pion g7
voilà mais du coup la position noir
justement est très très forte sur case
blanche
du fait de ces structures depuis une de
pions et à l'aise sur cases noires grâce
aux fous de cannes marque est toujours
là et la dame aussi qu'ils peuvent venir
qui est déjà sûre cases noires qui
peuvent venir aider se fout aussi donc
c'est très très solide mais très
resserrée aussi puisque le fou ces huit
encore moins de casse possible voilà
prêt à six ne peut pas louer b6 pour
sortir le fouet à 617 l'enfant on peut
aussi en baisse et on peut mais à 6 on
pourra pas voilà donc c'est ça enlève
encore une case à ceux hélas des quatre
bombes logiques
maintenant je vous des 4 on a transposé
alors si une sorte de variante c'est une
slam je crois bien c'est le terme
c'est une belle slab avec ces six décès
et là où cinq tout de suite alors ça
c'est un coup responsable de marie tout
de suite eu 5 sans doute profitant du
fait que les blancs non par ok encore
qui s'il ya des échanges au centre bell
le fait que le roi soit encore aux
saintes pourrait on pourrait arriver à
le dire ok peut-être certaines variantes
ça paraît dangereux quand même parce que
cinq bons la présente des scènes clés
seraient au noir un pion isolé après
pions prat en pions prend ou même si on
reprend du cavalier simplement un
échange et le pion décennie sera tout
seul puis donc d'éliminer le pion à
celle de prendre des cinq et on laisse
les noirs avec un pur isolé bon le pion
isolé ça peut être une faiblesse à long
terme mais aussi en milieu de jeu ça
libère les colonnes notamment la colonne
c'est sera libérée si on a le pion des
cinq isolé et puis on a la colonne le e
semi ouverte aussi qui laisse des places
pour les tours et puis des cases de jeu
ça donne un jeu aussi plus libre noir
donc il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients
il faut voir ce qui va se passer après
le 5 elles se trompent pas ou chez nina
elle prend carrément en d5
alors ça paraît surprenant mais vous
allez voir la suite en fait ça n'est pas
tellement l'idée c'est qu'en prenant des
cinq du cavalier bon on a l'air de on a
l'impression de perdre une pièce c'est
vrai mais on a fourni six cavaliers là
et on voit bien que la prise du pion des
ans 1,5 fera une fourchette cavaliers
fou voilà ce qui fait qu'on va récupérer
la pièce en l'attaquant deux fois
simplement il ya un coût intermédiaire
donc on va voir la suite
donc c'est c'est quand même un bon coup
on va voir pourquoi difficile d'analyser
tout ça en détail faut pas oublier non
plus qu'on en partie rapide
donc on va pas regarder toutes les
ramifications ces 20 minutes chacun ça
va ça va vite
alors s'il ya plus de dix secondes par
coup ça doit être un quart d'heure plus
10 secondes par coup je sais plus la
cadence exactement c'est pas très
important
c'est à peu près ça donc c'est prend
cavaliers il a maintenant des prendre 5
avec fourche est bon très bien mais il
ya un petit échec intermédiaire du fou
possible échec ce que fait marie
d'ailleurs alors il y avait d'autres
variantes possibles on peut aussi jouer
damas un échec parce que ce qu'on n'a
pas peur de fou 6-3 parce qu'on y
installe en maîtrise fou et la batterie
d'un vous obligerait le fou à reprendre
reprendre la dame encore avec échec et
après on enlèvera le cavalier qui ont
prises donc
d'un échec est possible aussi avec des
idées de prendre après en scène sans
doute de prendre 4 et la dame attaquera
la case au symbole c'est très compliqué
en fait on peut pas tout voir mais c'est
une entre très intéressante et une
position a analysé chez soi en détail
fou bekkat d'abord échecs dont très bien
alors voilà justement profite du fait
que le roi justement da par ok c'est
peut-être l'idée de marier deux joues
cento même si ça a pas l'air mauvais
pour lui blanc puisqu'on voit bien
toutes les prises qui sont possibles la
royale fun et quasiment forcé on va pas
mettre le roi plus au centre en face de
la dame non c'est pas bon faire une
passe à serait pas une bonne idée
et là tout simplement calais j'écarte
voilà très bien cavalier j4 commence à
faire un peu pression sur le pion aux 5
on a une pièce de plus mais on a quand
même déjà donné un pion et puis alors
c'est pas fini parce qu'il va se passer
c'est prend des cinq races et prend des
cinq champions et est en plus ce pion
est en plus protégés de fois il attaque
et que deux fois donc en échange de la
pièce là deux pions de plus et en plus
des pions centraux oui c'est quand même
force
donc là il ya deux plans possible
j'essaie de garder la pièce de plus par
exemple je joue cavalier en baisse 6
commence à attaquer v5 c'est possible
mais à plein défense
pour les blancs simplement joue des six
lots 5 étant extrêmement bien défendu on
a on aurait dans ce cas là un duo de
pions qui devient extrêmement pénibles
dans le camp noir malgré la pièce de
moins les noirs sont un peu ficelé c'est
la première option quand même
et deuxièmement c'est ce que fait marie
jeu reprend simplement le pion central
parce que après des échanges quasiment
forcé à 1,5 la dame va aussi prendre le
pion des 5
donc je récupère tout ça il faut faire
après le bilan des courses cavale et
prend qu'elle les prend et maintenant
après fou prend 1 prend alors bilan des
courses par le fait que le foot attaqué
faut que les blanches quelque chose
j'aime bien moins parce que le pion à
eux maintenant et en plus on le voit
c'est net mais en échange du pion - j'ai
fini mon développement quasiment ya plus
que le foie sortir les tours sont liés
et par contre les blancs non par ok donc
le roi et des rockets les tours sont pas
liés et ça va être long et pénible
d'activer ce
les tours parce que si on joue g3 on se
heurte affouages trois échecs et on peut
pas sortir l'euro un g2 alors en plus
ils à tours emprise la jetta mais la
dame donc j'ai trois départs de
possibles et si on joue f3 plus tard
pour enlever le roi comment commence à
être fait sur quatre mois c'est à dire
que le pion aux trois s'affaiblit et si
on pousse un le 4 on a une diagonale
noir l'un qui devient extrêmement
faibles donc des attaques possibles
contre le roi sans compter que derrière
f5 pourra ouvrir le jeu pour la tour
eiffel face au roi donc voyez que ça ne
s'est en fait extrêmement difficile pour
les blancs de s'activer
donc cette variante est peut-être assez
théorique et propose en échange du pion
donc pour les blancs un jeu dynamique
pour les noix donc la dame b deux très
jolis coups je défends à la fois le fou
et je crée une menace c'est toujours
mieux de créer des menaces puisque ça
oblige les noirs à trouver à jouer un
coup à part le coup et 6 est proscrit je
peux pas jouer et 6 on peut le montrer
un petit piège attaque le fou mais
simplement fou en f4 en c4 et c'est fini
la partie est perdue donc ça c'est pas
c'est pas une bonne idée pourquoi
puisque la dame bien sûr et cloud et
voilà ça c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire
c'est revoyez donc c'est pas simple de
protéger g7
si je joue j'ai 6 g affaibli
terriblement mes cases noires je me
prends une attaque extrêmement pénible
donc mariage ou la vente
lapointe en fait de ses doigts rien
probablement très jolie n'ont pas ici
justement fois trois voies la fois trois
très surprenant je mets le faux emprise
oui mais la dame peut pas prendre
vraiment puisque je prends le fou et en
plus j attaquerai la tour ce qui
obligerait donc les blanc à jouer la
tour vers le centre et les noirs
finissent leur développement rapidement
avec un drap blanc toujours mal placé et
qui empêche la tour a h1n1 rentré en jeu
donc avec un bon jeu en termes
d'activité donc voit trois très
intéressant si la dame vient en c3 mais
je reviens ou b4 et je poursuis la dame
je vous rappelle que là les noirs ont
simplement besoin d'une partie nulle à
cause de la première partie gagnée sur
décalage horaire donc dam des quatre
châteaux ou tard les blancs pourront
répéter ou deux fois mais d'amd 4 et
forcé si on veut aussi de jouer pour le
gain et les blancs peuvent vous pour le
guen ils ont quand même non plus bon la
partie la partie est bien entamée pour
quelqu'un qui veut jouer pour le gain
puisque donc
elle est asymétrique matériel contre
dynamisme c'est tout ce que peut on
souhaiter les blancs pour essayer
d'avoir une partie ou toute les chances
sont permises dans prend fou prend très
bientôt
quasiment forcé ça simplifie donc marie
ici n'a pas peur de rentrer dans une
finale elle estime que son activité
finalement compense le pion de moins ce
qui est pas évident à première vue mais
on va voir quelles joueuses jouent
précis et sans peur fou 17 ont très bien
un petit bleu faut maintenant je menace
très certainement simplement de venir en
c6 avec un très très très bons fous bien
placé il ya plus problème sur les pions
à aider avec un fond puisqu'ils visent
le centre
j'ai plus qu'à compléter mon
développement voire même jeu je me
l'instauration vite tout simplement pour
prendre la colonne celle qui sans doute
encore meilleur que ce que je vais dire
tour à ses 8 pour prendre la colonne
s'est sans doute encore donc la foule f3
voilà très bon coup de blanc foule f3
ben je profite du fait que le fouillent
sortie pour attaquer cette faiblesse un
bessette et c'est pas évident pour les
noirs de trouver une défense parce que
voilà tour si la tour vient en b 8 pour
protéger bessette l'autre fou peut
attaquer la tour et la harceler et c'est
pas évident c'est pas évident il peut se
passer ici des des choses et les blancs
peuvent s'activer donc la marie vous
d'abord foulée cinq échecs puisque si le
four vient à eux deux je peux revenir en
c6 avec une bonne position ou voir en 17
ans pas
puis proposer répéter les coups c'est
pas dans l'intérêt des blancs les blancs
n'ont pas joué le roi eux parce que s'il
joue le roi en a eu un
eh bien on est on est toujours pas on
n'est toujours pas activé
autour on aura du mal à venir sur la
deuxième parce que si on vient en d2 on
va se prendre un échec du fou et on est
obligé d'aller sur la colonne c'est avec
les tours qui vont venir faire les
échecs il faut aller en juin ça c'est
sûr et l'on peut espérer active le roi
soit par h-20 h 2 soit par h3 pardon h 2
il en a pas peur d'un échec puisque j'ai
trois par bien ça c'est une possibilité
même si c'est un peu long et les noirs
vont jouer rapidement ou plus tard
essayer de revenir en f1 puis en deux
mais il faudra que ce fou soit éliminé
justement la marie faut qu'elle fasse
quelque chose contre le pion bessette
bombay elle propose charge des fous mais
avec le risque fou préemption prend un
pion faible mais c'est ce que font les
blanches on en comprend
puis on prend un pion faibles ceux qui
ont effectivement mais en fait les
blancs peuvent pas à venir en c1 pour
l'attaqué donc il est faible sans l'être
voilà ils facilement on voit très vite
marie a très vite vu qu'elle pouvait
jouer rapidement en maintenant ses 5
puis c4 pour échanger ce pion faible
part pourquoi il fait parce qu'il est
isolé il isolé alors que les pions
blancs eux sont tous liés à ces deux
sont liés ces quatre sont liés donc ça
c'est un peu faible mais du moment qu'on
peut les changer rapidement
ces cinq c4 on peut pas parler vraiment
de faiblesses
oui elle a pas peur du pian 2 - toujours
mais maintenant que les fous sont plus
là au wef très bien positionné
l'allemand jouer c'est seulement très
bien joué bien sûr aux f1 3e 2 et ça y
est les tours sont liés mais on pourra
pas venir sur la colonne c'est c5 c3 c4
voilà tu arrives en on n'a pas peur
puisque bien sûr sur pions prend ses
quatre tours fc vite et on peut pas
empêcher la reprise
3-2 alors là on prend part à petit sur
la prise les blancs reprennent et le
foot attaqué et on perd l'initiative un
petit peu donc il faut pas se presser
touré fils et vit très bien voilà
facilement on active la dernière pièce
on laisse la tour en a 8 parce que
éventuellement veut plus et à 5 à 4
voilà donc et voire même c'est tout on
va la mettre en b 8 pour attaquer b3
pour menacer puis on prend puis on prend
tout reprendre voilà on active les
pièces au maximum et là où chez nina
nous fait la même finalement que en
partie longue
rappelez-vous alors c'est pas la même
position du tout à fait seul et même
coup un peu douteux b4 alors pas
terrible secours parce que bon c'était
pas évident de trouver un bon coup non
plus bien c'est sûr parce que là ont
menacé quand même avec les noirs ici de
prendre en b3 avec le fou qui est
attaqué bon c'est sûr que c'est pas
évident
mais apprendre b3 apprendre des trois
tours prendre je peux prendre à trois
avec la tour puis après doubler les
tours et prendre le pion à 6 et j'ai une
finale avec un point de plus bon faut
savoir que les finales deux tours avec
quatre contre trois sont considérés
comme étant nulle au niveau d'un grand
maître 1 après au niveau d'un joueur qui
est un grand maître je dis pas mais
l'essai grand maître la save
ça veut faire nul en finale deux tours
surtout quand les pions sont tous du
même côté
donc les blancs savent tout ça donc ils
jouent des quatre pour essayer de garder
des chances de gain probablement mais ce
coup semble un peu faible quand même
parce que tout rabais 8 et ça justifie
encore plus le positionnement noir la
position ici est maximale pour les noirs
l'activité maximale ce pion en plus et
bien placés parce qu'il contrôle des 3l
surtout b3 dont qui l'empêchent de toute
façon une tour devenir et à attaquer le
fou à 3 qui est quand même tout petit
peu enfermé mais bon les noirs vraiment
sont au maximum de leur activité malgré
le pion - tours à b1 entraînions
surprotège des quatre est simplement
tombé 5
assez rapidement par marier ici une
position toujours très solide la tourne
à noter ici que la tour en bessin qui
est protégé par à 6
on peut menacer ici avec les noirs
pourquoi pas de venir chatouiller les
pions sur les droits un bon je pense que
c'est pas l'objectif mais l objectif ça
peut être de doubler les tours en fait
doubler les tours et le plan b 4 sera
perdue puisqu'on menacera fou prend
voire même si les blancs font pas
attention
imaginons que les tours soit doublé du
côté noir en menaces à 5 puisque en cas
de prise on perd la tour est apprécié à
prendre mais on a deux pions ici lié
avancer là attention et blanc qu'elle
joue très précis et surtout rage des
vins on active la tour vers le centre on
menace de venir par exemple en d4 pour
prendre ces 4
et en plus en cas de sources et des huit
ça annule la menace sur b4 puisque en
cas de fou prend vous prend un tour
prend tout reprend tout reprend il ya le
fameux match du couloir à la fin c'est
matt du couloir
donc ce coup-là invalide la manoeuvre
tour cb vite donc il faut jouer un coup
pour éliminer cette menace du match du
couloir et marie joue le efficace et
précis f6 et non pas bien sûr j'ai si ça
enlève rien puisque le fou contre les
cannois et m6 plutôt qu à six parce
qu'on veut que le roi a ouvert le centre
première chose si on sort on veut plutôt
aller vers le centre c'est toujours
mieux est de en plus cette petite
structure de pure en 1912 contre le fou
voilà vous est moins libre
ici par exemple peut pas aller du tout
en 5 et pourra jamais y aller il peut
pas nier la tour mais on peut imaginer
plus tard joué quatre ou cinq si on
avait joué h6 ça laisse des libertés au
fou que ici qui s'ils n'existent pas
alors là activation du roi roi des deux
les blancs comprennent que c'est bien ça
serait bien que ce roi finalement
arrivants ces deux voire même en c3 pour
faire pression sur le pion c4 mais
évidemment roi des deux permet la
manoeuvre suivante tour des huit échecs
quand ces deux et simplement tout
reprendre
et là où chez nina pouvait prendre du
roi mais c'est parce qu'elle va faire
alors on regarde pourquoi ce roi prend
simplement regarder très joli à 5
et c'est fini d4 est perdu on peut pas
prendre puisqu'il ya tout reprend un
échec et ensuite on va prendre du plomb
avait deux pions liés nous sommes en a
récupéré le pion mais on a sans doute
même l' avantage puisque on a une belle
belle avancée de du côté dames avec des
pièces extrêmement bien placé et c'est
les blancs qui vont lutter pour la nul
donc sûr
roi des deux tours des huit échecs à ces
deux tours prend on prend de la tour ils
n'ont pas du moins pour éviter à cents
et là simplement le problème c'est que
ça permet vous prendrez quatre ans voilà
le coup aura des deux îles sans doute un
peu
de faiblards ici dans cette position
aurait fallu que les blancs jouent
peut-être un groupe lui plus punchy mais
c'est pas facile on voit bien que les
noirs étaient très actifs tomber un clou
le fou donc attention un coup comme à 5
se heurte à a3 ça marche pas si je
protège le fou avec à 5 mais la tour
simplement et protégé il suffit
d'enlever le fou pas de problème ils se
trompent pas ce serait une erreur
attention ça serait une erreur ici de
prendre le fou c3 alors pourquoi ce
serait une heure on va le voir
imaginons ici que les noirs prennent le
pouls c3 alors cette variante là
seraient perdus à cause de la varende
suivante tout reprendre b5 simplement
apprend b5 et forcé maintenant roi prend
ses 3 et après roy f7 simplement on joue
à quatre casse
le duo pions et non pas le choix il faut
prendre 1 4
et là on peut jouer ce droit penser qu'à
tout simplement voilà et là on va avoir
quatre pions contre 3 est très
certainement la finale de pions risque
d'être gagnante pour les blancs c'est
pas sûr mais il faut calculer mais les
noix ont pas le temps d'aller faire le
tour là bas parce que ici simplement sur
roy e 6 3 des 4 et forcé faut vite
prendre ce pur ans sans réfléchir les
noirs eux doivent activer le roy on
reprend 1,4 hélas échoué la partie est
tendue faut bien réfléchir à ça on peut
jouer sans doute passé 4 ce qui
obligeait le roi blanc à rester en 1/4
faut jouer notre cou et l'a pas facile
pour lui blanc de trouver un coût mais
il ya quand même capio contre trois avec
possibilité de se créer un pion passé
donc on joue à quatre points des trois
et c'est chaud c'est chaud alors si on
peut pas plus et donc il faut jouer f3
et là est-ce qu'on peut aller chercher
les pions c'est pas sûr parce que si on
va trop loin par un f2 qui se passe f4
et suivi de hossein qu'est le roi ne
pourra jamais rattraper les pions donc
on peut pas aller chercher les pions et
laurent blanc va revenir
donc c'est pas évident a calculé cette
finale c'est peut-être nul quand même en
étant précis mais pour les noirs mais il
ya des risques de perdre sérieux donc il
faut faire attention on vous prend des
quatre tours b 1
fou des six tours d un revient en b 4
avec marié tranquille et la a4 attaque
la tour alors il faut pas que la toile
nul pas attention il peut y avoir un
clouage a pris un bon jour 1b vite parce
que quand ça dans ce cas de clouage je
peux venir en d6 protégeant la tour mais
tour des quatre sans doute encore
meilleur puisque ça attaque le pion c4
après fou prend ces trois rois princes
et rois
je commande pas trop parce que là on a
déjà envie et notez donc là les filles
ont plus qu une minute chacune à la
pendule plus 10 secondes par coup donc
là si vous voulez on je me contente du
minimum tomber trois échecs au apprend
tomber deux très bien on active la tour
pour ramasser faut être précis il faut
pas laisser les noirs ramassé tout ça il
faut pas oublier qu'on essaie de on est
quand même en 16e de finale du
championnat du monde on essaie quand
même de revenir au score on va pas faire
n'importe quoi
thorez 4 voilà c'est le quasiment forcé
ses forces et tout reste quatre ans
protégé f2 c'est fondamental les blancs
attention du jeu parce que ce pion à 6
mine de rien
si les barres il va le prendre avec le
roi par exemple un pion à passer c'est
dur
attention attention il faut être précis
pour l'instant il n'y a pas danger mais
il faut faire gaffe on rêve 7 h 4 alors
plus on a quatre contre trois ans ici on
essaie de contenir les pions noirs six
mois ces trois attaques la toya où tu
vas parce que si si la torres sur la
deuxième ça permet au roi de venir en
bep cap et ensuite en a cinq
et si la tour est sur l'a7 colonnes pour
empêcher le roi devenir la tour peut
maintenant revenir en jeu voilà par
exemple en b 4 et menaçant touré cheick
suivi de la prise
marie se trompent pas tour à deux
attaques le pion mais trois des quatre
et là il faut absolument créer du
contre-jour l'autre côté ce coup h4 est
peut-être un peu douteux parce que là
l'espace g5
je prends f prend et on voit tout de
suite qu'il ya une contre auchan ce noir
parce que ses deux pions là
potentiellement sur les avances assez
loin ils vont pouvoir on va pouvoir
jouer h3 et donc se créer un pion passé
voilà alors que si le blanc est pas
jouer h4
c'était pas possible donc bon voyez
c'est bon c'est compliqué à plein de
subtilité une minute à la pendule sais
pas évidemment
la tour est royale par des blancs
pourquoi pas mal placé la tour quand
même là peut-être en fuite s'était mieux
puisque la tour en f3 on voit bien
qu'elle est bloquée par le pion aux
trois risques se fait un peu oublier la
rive trois là un peu hors du jeu donc à
h5 voilà le plan c de seuil et de se
mettre en position d'obtenir un pion
passé j'ai 3 bon pourquoi pas un peu
douteux encore une fois puisque ça
permet h 4 il en accueillant pas si tout
de suite
marie se pressent pas toutefois elle
joue tour d2 pourquoi pas autour des 2
éventuellement on peut voir un des sites
protégés à 6 je passe sur soul idées et
une autre idée derrière tours d2
regardez tu as pris trois à cinq sans
doute les blancs l'ont pas vu regardez
mari joue très précis alors là faut pas
se tromper et il faut savoir calculer un
magnifique combinaison de marie en c'est
là qu'elle le montre tout son talent
dans l'est dans les combinaisons
tactiques de fin de partie 2 minutes
parti autant dans les ouvertures jusqu'à
présent on a vu que c'était surtout avec
les noirs 1 qu'elle avait des problèmes
on l'a bien vu à dans ce match en tout
cas autant tactiquement et positionne
helmand après après l'ouverture c'est
c'est la boucherie la tour des cinq
échecs on va prend 1,6 bon ça paraît
très bon pour les blancs j'essaye j'aime
bien passé mais regardez c'est là que la
tour eiffe 3eme place et y regarder 13,5
force échange des tours énorme c'est ça
l'idée de marie sur tours d2 on laisse
jouer à sec on veut échanger des taux
pourquoi un autre pion passé il va à
dame aussi vite que celui là la
condition d'être précis de pas se
tromper et les finales de dames pour les
gagner il faut se lever tôt surtout
quand on a juste un peu en avance et que
ce pion à la en plus le pion d'avant
cirad il est presque pas avancer le roi
sera très loin on voit bien tu tivement
que aux mines dame là une dame là on se
doute que c'est assez nul bon ceci dit
on voit bien aussi que le problème
d'avoir d'hamelin et dames là la
première qui fait d'armé en pet shop de
faire dame mais vous allez voir que
c'est là que marié a tout calculé et que
ou chez nina
à essayer de s'en sortir mais vous allez
voir ça marche pas donc là si la tour à
noter que donc j'ai dit tout reste roi
je trouve ça un peu
pas terrible mais si la toa a été
ensuite eh bien on aurait pu garder leur
tour active c'est pas la même partie
bien sûr donc un mari aurait pas laisser
faire ça il aurait fallu que je trouve
autre chose donc la tour pro f 5
on va prendre 5 et là maintenant si les
noirs les blancs jouent à droite ici b6
pour éviter de se mettre prendre un
échec quand tu y as dame en robe et 6
alors à cash 4 à 5 h 3 à 6 h 2 h 7 h une
dame en premier et c'est fini y a pas
d'âme donc les noirs font nulle voire
même gagne la partie parce que je pense
qu'entre le pion à on va faire des
échecs on ramène la dame et à la fin le
roi est obligé de venir à huit blocs et
on ramasse les derniers pions et ça doit
être gagnant enfin faut faire gaffe aux
pattes mais c'est gagnant puis en plus
cela nul suffit donc ça va pas donc là
il ya quand même un joli coup pour les
blancs qui permet de s'en sortir un peu
en partie très jolie que quatre
magnifiques
alors que quatre jeux fait échec et
évidemment on a compris cette diagonale
est très importante si le roi vient là
vous comprenez qu'après dames c'est aux
blancs de jouer dame échec on ramasse la
dame habite donc c'est un coup subtil
loi il faut pas prendre le pire on sait
ça l'astuce alors on va le voir tout de
suite regardé maintenant après
simplement dame prend on se trompe pas
avec les bains il faut jouer roi en
baissse ispahan bessette ce qu'on bouche
réelle idée hein c'est pas du tout
l'idée si on joue au roi
les six maintenant h4 on peut prendre ou
pas je pense comme il est bon on a
intérêt à prendre on garder un maximum
de possibilités de gains et maintenant
si dame avait simplement maintenant on
fait table et échec au roi et on ramasse
et on gagne la partie
donc piège 4 piège il n'en mari tombe
pas dans le piège c'est grossier
rome 5 mais maintenant quand je fais
d'am-dam l'adami s'ils n'empêchent pas
enfin quand je fais d'amis sion le pion
aux quatre ne me permet pas de contrôler
la case habite
ceci dit après web et 6h 4h 5h 3 à 6 h 2
à 7 h une dame à huit dames
d'en prendre quatre
je récupère le pion tranquille j'ai pas
peur de dame prend dames puisque roy
prend et c'est le roi qui est proche des
pions pas le roi blanc
ensuite ils suivent il va suivre wave 3
roi prend un air de rap range étroit ou
alors s'il est bien joué 4 on échange
tout et c'est nul donc là on voit bien
que c'est déjà certainement nul
encore quelques coups qui sont joués
mais voyez la combinaison quand même
magnifique de marica changer les tours
en ayant tout calculé d'un 8 échecs
croit fcn tout simplement on reste
pourquoi roi hussein parce qu'on reste
pas loin des pions en cas d'échangé
on voit même on peut menacer après
devenir angers 4 avec le roi on n'a pas
peur en fait seront est trop loin et on
va on va gober ses pions de toute façon
c'est pas un problème d'homme 17 enfin
on va les gober si les blancs arrête de
faire des échecs mais s'ils font que des
échecs ça sera du lot 6 3 5 5 échecs et
on n'a pas peur d'emmener 5la les
blondes tente un dernier truc
ils savent que là s'il continue à faire
les échecs c'est nul et 6 échange les
dames le roi empêche le râble en devenir
et a pas de problème les pions ne
peuvent pas lutter contre moi c'est trop
fort loin donc il va les gober et pas de
problème et puis il n'ya pas de pompe à
ses protégés ça passe pas
donc la f3 subtil intéressant essayer de
trouver une petite arnaque mais ça
marche pas marie sans peur et sans
reproche boom dans prend on va prendre
la finale depuis un nul vous allez voir
trois des quatre bassines et blanc
pousse je prends je prends appui le roi
viennent manger
pas de problème donc croise et 6 pour
essayer quelque chose avec laurent et
bloquer aussi par le roi noir 1 re et 3
et s'est terminée f4 puis on prend f4f 4
puis on prend avec quatre ans il est
blanc joue g4 ce pion va à dame avant le
pont blanc safra nul donc après j'ai
pris un f4 roi prend f4 parties nulles
parties nulles donc marie qui a gagné la
première partie donc sur décalage
horaire on peut dire ça comme ça ils ont
surfé en fait en pratique et bien se
retrouvent après cette partie nulle
victorieuse de ce 16e de finale donc
bravo marie puisque marie sebag se
retrouve maintenant qualifié en
huitièmes de finale de ce championnat du
monde 2015 et ça nous promet donc des
huitièmes
extrêmement intéressant à suivre pour
les français pour les francophones qui
suivent marie sebag pour espérer qu'elle
se qualifie en quarts de finale avec
donc un huitième qui risque d'être
extrêmement tendue puisque le niveau
monte bien sûr plus on passe des tours
et plus le niveau monte et ça va être
très très intéressant à suivre avec
marie survolté très probablement d'avoir
gagné ce match de façon assez
convaincante finalement malgré disons
bah oui malgré ce ce point un peu par
forfait mais enfin je veux dire est là
elle a quand même démontré sa capacité à
remonter à tenir des positions
inférieure est donc finalement une
capacité à éviter de se faire dominer en
match et au point l a jamais été mené au
score donc là c'est quand une preuve de
très bon niveau et de très bonne forme
pour marie en espérant que je joue mieux
ces ouvertures peut-être dans la suite
et obtiennent de meilleures positions
pour pour jouer des parties plus
plus punchy voilà merci de nous avoir
suivi sur des bonal tv je vous dis donc
à très vite pour suivre les huitièmes de
finale de ce championnat du monde
féminin 2015
au revoir